Russia has been using the Shaheed 136
drone shown here to attack targets
across the energy infrastructure across
the whole of Ukraine
um that seems to pause on the 17th of
November but restarted again just the
other day almost certainly that was a
result of a resupply from Iran we
understand that a an Iranian cargo
aircraft landed at Moscow just two days
ago Russia's been running very short of
weapons not only these drones but also
short-range ballistic missiles range of
about 500 kilometers with about a 500
kilogram Warhead now Iran's been very
happy to provide support for this the
question is what does it want in return
clearly Iran does want an equitable
partnership but it also Russia has
offered su-35 multi-role fighter
aircraft it's offered helicopters and
also surface-to-air missile systems and
protection
um the and well most worrying it's also
helped with its fledgling nuclear
program all of this has very worry
implications for of stability around the
local region of course we returned to a
focus of events on the ground actually
in Ukraine itself the Russian priority
Remains the donbass region here and
particularly Focus around bakmut which
have been tried to encircle for many
weeks north east and south but they've
not managed to take the West very
difficult get detailed information about
what's happening here because the
Ukraine and Russian version of events do
differ but it is described as a hell
hole and certainly president zielinski
described ahmood as being in Ruins from
a Ukrainian perspective they tend to be
focused on just north of October trying
to cut off the logistic supply lines of
Russia down to our moods and if we zoom
out Ukraine is also trying to do exactly
the same thing down in Harrison the
Russian forces that Denise the danipro
river here cutting off the logistics
supply lines and literally only the
other day
three ammunition dumps were destroyed
and also 20 military vehicles looking
more strategically Low Winter may have
arrived it may have slowed The Temper of
operations
however the conflict is no nearer ending
it hasn't stopped Putin hinting that he
was ready to negotiate when he's
actually got no intention of doing that
at all it clearly is trying to put
pressure on president zielinski make him
appear to blame in reality this war is
not just being fought on the
battlefields it's also being fought in
an information domain and it shows the
real importance of making sure we take
nothing at face value